and if you're not ready to go clubbing
just yet caesar's has a more
sophisticated option for you
as rocky is checking out the new park
west gallery
in the forum shops where she ran into
some of the artists themselves
yeah we can all use a little inspiration
during this time and park west gallery
here at the form shops has
plenty of it a lot of inspiration yeah
yes and this wall here is yours
personally
you've been you've been painting for
since you were 13 you said
since i was a young child yeah it then
when i went out west when i was 13 it
really inspired me to start painting the
southwest so
i've been painting full time for about
25 years now with parkwoods gallery wow
that's such a
you're living the dream oh i am living
here every day is art class
i just i i throw color around and paint
from the heart and
as you can see i painted a tribute to
the nation i'm dedicating that to the
vietnam
veteran uh war so you can see with the
color bar there
and i have a big fondness and affinity
for the southwest as well
like we were saying earlier when i was
13 years old i came out here for the
first time and i was just
enamored with the culture and the colors
uh for example like the headdress over
here there was just something about the
beauty and the color about it so
to incorporate originally i started off
as an abstract artist
and i've gone full circle now abstract
expressionism
but uh so i'm incorporating your my
abstracts and it's interesting because
if you look at these you know you find
out different kind of curiosities and
nuances and incorporating them with
content as well with the headdress
amalgamation of both if you will
beautiful so when people come down to
visit the gallery
with an open mind like accepting
everything and and look at all these
paintings and
and don't try to read into them like a
paragraph right listen to them like a
song
you know listen with your eyes if you
will that's beautiful i'm telling you
that's why you're the actor
thank you so much tim we're going to
show you a few more paintings here at
park
gallery coming up later in the four
o'clock show we'll send back to you